- [Instructor] A 20-meter ladder
is leaning against a wall.
The distance X of T between
the bottom of the ladder
and the wall is increasing at a rate
of three meters per minute.
At a certain instant T sub zero
the top of the ladder is
a distance Y of T sub zero
of 15 meters from the ground.
What is the rate of change of the angle
theta of T between the ground
and the ladder at that instant?
So what I want to do is draw this out.
And really, the first
step is to think about,
well, what equation will be helpful
for us to solve this problem.
And then we might just go ahead and
actually solve the problem.
So a 20-meter ladder is
leaning against a wall.
So let me draw ourselves a wall here.
That is my wall.
Now let me draw our 20-meter ladder.
So maybe it looks something like that.
So that is 20
meters.
They say the distance X
of T between the bottom
of the ladder and the wall.
So, this distance right over here.
This is
this distance right over here is
X of T.
They say it's increasing at a rate of
three meters per minute.
So, we know that we could either say
X prime of T, which is the same thing
as DX DT.
Is equal to three meters,
I'll write it out because
it's hard if I said M per M
it might not be that clear.
Meters per minute, so they give us
that piece of information.
So the rate of change of
X, with respect to time,
they gave us that.
At a certain sub T sub zero
the top of the ladder is a distance
of 15 meters.
So the top of the ladder, so
let's make this very clear.
So, this distance
right
over here
is Y of T.
Y of T.
And they say, at time T sub zero
Y of T is 15 meters.
So let me just write it
in here, Y of T sub zero
is equal to 15 meters.
And so, maybe let me write
this right over here.
This is Y of T sub zero.
Let's just assume that we're drawing it
at that moment T sub zero, because I think
that's going to be important.
Y of T sub zero is equal to 15
meters.
So they want to know,
what is the rate of change
of the angle theta between
the ground and the ladder.
And this is saying theta
is also going to change
with respect to time.
There's going to be a function of time
between the ground and the
ladder at that instant.
So theta, get a new color here.
Theta is this angle right
over here, this is theta.
And it's also going to
be a function of time.
So, what we'll always want to do in these
related rates problems is we want to
set up an equation, and
really, an algebraic equation
maybe a little bit of
trigonometry involved.
That relates the things
that we care about.
And then we're likely to have to take
the derivative of both sides of that
in order to relate the related rates.
So let's see.
We want to know
we want to know the rate of change
of the angle between
the ground and the ladder at that instant.
So what we need to figure out
we want to figure out,
theta prime, at T sub zero.
This is what we want to figure out.
Now, they've given us
some interesting things,
they've given us, I
guess, our rate of change
of X with perspective time is constant
at three meters per minute.
And, we know what Y is at that moment.
So let's see, can we create a relationship
because they gave us DX DT
it'll actually be more useful
to find a relationship
between X and theta,
and then take the
derivative of both sides.
And then use this information possibly
to figure out what the appropriate
value of X or theta is
at that moment.
So let's do that.
So how does X relate to theta?
Well, we use a little bit of
trigonometry right over here.
If you took the hypotenuse
times the cosine of theta
you would get X.
So let me write this right up here, X of T
X of T
is equal to
the hypotenuse
20 meters, because that's
the length of the ladder,
times the cosine
cosine of theta.
And I can say the cosine of theta of T
just to make it clear that this
is a function of time.
This comes straight out of trigonometry.
Actually, our basic trig, trigonometric
function definitions.
Now, why is this useful, why
do I think this is useful?
Well let's think about
what happens when I take
the derivative of both
sides using the chain rule.
On the left hand side, I am going to have
an X prime of T.
And then that's going to
be equal to, what do I end
up with on the right hand side?
Well, using the chain
rule, first, I'll take
the derivative with respect to theta.
And so that's just going to be
negative 20 sine
of
theta of T.
And I need to multiple that
times theta prime of T.
So what I can do is, say hey look,
at T sub zero, I know
what X prime of T is.
I could try to figure out
what sine of theta of T is
and then I'll just solve for this
right over there.
So let's do that.
So, at T sub zero
so at T is equal to
T sub zero.
What we're gonna have X prime of T.
Well that, at every time,
it's three meters per minute
we'll assume that our rates
are in meters per minute.
And just our values are in meters
when we're talking about distance
and our angles are in radians.
So, this is going to be equal to three
is equal to
negative 20
times sine of theta of T
times the derivative of
data with respect to time.
So, how do we figure
out what sine of theta
of T is going to be?
Well, let's just use that
other information they gave us.
And I'm gonna scroll down a little bit
to get a little bit more real estate.
So sine of theta, let
me write it over here.
Sine
of theta
at time T sub not,
that's what we care about
T is equal to T sub not.
What's that gonna be?
Well sine is opposite over hypotenuse.
So that's gonna be Y
at T sub not.
Over our hypotenuse
of 20 meters.
Well that's going to be equal to
that's going to be equal to, they tell us,
Y of T sub not is 15 meters
over 20 meters.
Which is the same thing as three fourths.
So, by this yellow
information, they actually
told us that this right over here
is going to be equal to three fourths.
So this times three fourths
times the rate of change
of theta
with respect to T.
And so now we just have to
solve for this and we're done.
So, this is going to be what's
negative 20 times three fourths?
That is negative 15.
If we divide both sides by negative 15
we get
theta prime of T is equal to
three over negative 15.
Three over negative 15.
Which is the same thing as being equal to
negative one fifth.
And this, the units here would be in
radians per minute.
Because our rates are all in per minute.
So, if I wanted to I could write radians
per
minute.
Ideally I would write it
right over here.
But here you go.
We were able to figure out and
this is an interesting one.
Because, they give you
that information on Y
but really, use that information of Y
to figure out what sine of theta of T is.
But the equation you set
up involves X and theta.